MARK PELLEGRINI: Hi, I'm Mark.
JOHN ASMUTH: And I'm John.
MARK PELLEGRINI: We're both
engineers on the Google Cloud
SDK team.
Today we're going to be giving a
brief walk-through of the Cloud
SDK and specifically the new
gcloud command-line tool.
JOHN ASMUTH: Here
at Google we've
been working hard to create
a great Cloud Platform.
And we know that
for a lot of you
this means a great
command-line experience, too.
MARK PELLEGRINI:
The Google Cloud SDK
gives you everything you need
to work with the Google Cloud
Platform in a single
convenient package.
The new gcloud tool
is a complete rewrite
of the existing
Cloud command-line
interfaces you might be aware
of, with a specific focus
on product integration,
ease of use,
and, of course,
command-line power.
The best way to show
off what gcloud can do
is just to show you.
JOHN ASMUTH: Let's
start with a situation
we've all been in being a new
developer on a project team.
You're an experienced developer
and you know how to code
but you don't know the
tools your team uses,
the workflows they follow,
or how to get started.
Fortunately for us, this app
is built on the Google Cloud
Platform.
Your new tech lead tells you
to go grab the Google Cloud
SDK, that your project
name is gcloud-demo-io2014,
and that there's a
bug in production that
needs to be fixed right away.
MARK PELLEGRINI: We don't
really know where to start,
so we search for the
Google Cloud SDK.
And we land at Google's
Developer site,
where we see some
installation instructions.
JOHN ASMUTH: The set
up looks pretty easy.
Run one command to install.
And then run gcloud off
login on the command-line.
MARK PELLEGRINI: We've
created this one liner that
can take care of the whole
installation process.
If you're on a system with
bash, paste it into a terminal
and follow the instructions.
Follow the prompts to choose
some installation options.
And it will then
download and install
the latest version of the SDK.
OK.
So we have the Cloud SDK now.
The website said it
installed the gcloud tool.
That seems like a
good place to start.
JOHN ASMUTH: If we run
in gcloud with bashh
it's going to tell us
about all the things we
can do with gcloud.
The developer
site's instructions
mentioned running
gcloud off login.
So let's do that first.
When you run that
command it will take you
to an authentication page
where you authenticate
with your Google account.
And then you can give
gcloud permission
to work on your behalf.
MARK PELLEGRINI: OK.
Now we're logged in,
but we don't really
know what to do next.
Let's see if there any other
gcloud commands that look
promising.
There's a init command.
It sounds like that'll set
up a local workspace for us.
Looks like it needs a project.
But we have that information.
JOHN ASMUTH: gcloud
init is a command
that can set up a local
development environment for you
and bring in a repository
hosted by Google.
After the init finishes,
there's a directory
holding the project's
gear repository
with all our project files.
Now that we have
all the code, we
need to get work
on fixing this bug.
MARK PELLEGRINI:
First, let's try
to reproduce it with
the current code.
We need to run this app to
see where the problem is.
I know we run this
app on App Engine.
I bet there's a
command in gcloud
for running an App Engine app.
Well, it looks like
there's an app group.
That seems promising.
Great.
There's a run command.
Let's try that.
Looks like we need to give
it our project directory.
JOHN ASMUTH: gcloud app run will
run your app in a local testing
environment on your own
computer without receiving
any real traffic
from the internet.
Hey, it looks like it's running.
Let's check it out.
Sure enough, there's a problem.
This stack trace looks
pretty obvious though.
Let's try and fix it.
MARK PELLEGRINI: So first,
let's take a look at our source.
Well, I see what's wrong here.
How did this get
into production?
One of the nice things
about the local app server
is that it will automatically
reload your source
if it changes.
If we just refresh the page
we can see if our fix is good.
JOHN ASMUTH: Looks
like it's working now.
Now it's time to get
this fix submitted.
Since we're using Git, we can
use all the normal Git commands
and commit our change
and then push it back
to our project's repository.
You can also
configure your project
to deploy the app when you
push, but for this project
and for this demo, we
haven't enabled that feature.
MARK PELLEGRINI:
Instead, let's use
gcloud to redeploy the
app since it's currently
broken in production.
We need to tell it what
version to deploy to.
Once the deployment
is finished, we
can check on the production
site to see our fix in action.
JOHN ASMUTH: That's
pretty easy. gcloud
had everything we needed to
set up a local development
environment, make a
fix, test our app,
and then redeploy
back into production.
The unified command-line
and integrated help
really helped us figure
out the right path
to take to get where
we needed to go.
MARK PELLEGRINI: All right.
Let's say now that
we work in DevOps,
and we're responsible for
deploying a web application
across a farm of machines.
How can gcloud help us do this?
JOHN ASMUTH: First,
let's just start
with a bunch of empty VMs.
We just created them so
they're running Linux,
but they have
nothing else on them.
We want to have our web
application running on each one
and then set up a load
balancer to distribute traffic
among all of them so we can
increase our overall capacity.
MARK PELLEGRINI: We use gcloud
to push the files for a custom
web server to each machine
and to get it running.
When we're done,
we'll have our server
running on a fleet of
machines serving traffic
through a single IP.
We can probably configure
each VM manually
but there's a lot of them
and it would be really handy
if we can just script this.
Let's drop back into
the command-line
and see how to do
this using gcloud.
JOHN ASMUTH: First,
let's find the VMs
that we already have running.
We can get some basic
information about our cluster
by running with a list command.
It shows us the instance name
and IP among other things.
For this demo, we
only have a couple,
but really if there's
any more than one
we'd probably want
to script this.
Since the commands can
also get long sometimes,
we added a shell mode to gcloud.
Here we'll just run
gcloud compute --shell,
and every future gcloud command
can omit the first two words.
MARK PELLEGRINI: Next, we'll
create a target pool that
will refer to each of those VMs.
A target pool is
simply a grouping
of machine between
which the load
balancer can distribute traffic.
For the instances
to use, I can just
give it the output of the other
command that lists all of them.
Once the target pool is ready
we can create a forwarding rule.
A forwarding rule
accepts traffic on one IP
and does some basic
load balancing
between the VMs in the
pool we just created.
OK.
Forwarding rule's set up.
JOHN ASMUTH: Let's
see what IP we
need to connect to by listing
the forwarding rules available.
Then we can use cURL to
connect to the web server.
Of course, this isn't going
to work because there's
no actual software running
on that machine yet.
MARK PELLEGRINI:
Fortunately, we've
got a nice little Go program
that will serve HTTP.
It's pretty simple.
All it does is it tells you
the host name of the machine
that it's running on.
We're using a Mac
here but the program
can easily be
compiled for Linux.
JOHN ASMUTH: Now we need to
push our server to all the VMs.
We can use SSH and
SCP just like normal,
but gcloud can even
make this a bit easier.
The config SSH command
will create an alias
in your host file for
each of the available VMs
so that you can easily
SSH to all of them
without having to remember
their IP addresses.
Here we'll use bash in an
environment variable that
will hold each of our VM names.
Then we can use bash
to make a for loop that
will run SCP and send
our server to each
of the VMs in our project.
Look at them go.
Then once that's all set,
we can use the same variable
and another for loop--
very similar-- to iterate
over each VM and use SSH
to connect and run nohup
and sudo that will run our
server in the background.
MARK PELLEGRINI: Of
course, the firewall
doesn't have anything
open by default.
So we have to ask for an
exception for these machines
so that they can actually
receive HTTP traffic.
We use gcloud to indicate
that these machines will
be used as HTTP servers and
that port 80 should be opened.
Since we're making an API
call for each instance
we issue these commands in
parallel to save some time.
JOHN ASMUTH: Now if we make a
few cURL requests to the load
balancer, we can see
that it's all working
and the traffic's being
split between our VMs.
MARK PELLEGRINI: So
just like that, we've
set up a load balancer pool of
machines serving our web app.
Of course, this is
just one example
of the many powerful things
that gcloud command-line tool
can do for you.
Check out our developers
page to read more
about the services
we support or just
give gcloud a try on your own.
JOHN ASMUTH: And
we're continually
releasing new features.
So also be sure
to join our Google
group to get the latest updates.
MARK PELLEGRINI: Thanks.